we are transformed in a way through this
experience
all of us very much believe that this
feels like the most important movie
we've ever made
that is what every crew member focused
on every day and none more so than Ryan
coogler at the helm of it all
[Music]
Ryan is such a big heart and such a
great Storyteller
the actors that he's brought together
were filled with emotion and passion
reuniting with Ryan coogler it was
incredible his heart is really pure
and we should protect them at all costs
Ryan is an artist he has the heart to
listen to you
then look in your eyes and go deep not
just in the story but in your soul when
you get down to what makes this movie
human that is where Ryan really excels
[Music]
I think even in a world as Fantastical
and as magical and as exciting as the
Marvel Cinematic Universe
he just has an understanding of people
[Music]
there's an embracing of culture and Ryan
is going a step further and we're
remembering we're restoring we're
celebrating
above all it is a relationship movie
we'll have some incredible set pieces
but at the end of the day I think what
people are going to really remember is
the conversations
how do you move forward after losing
someone that meant so much to you
[Music]
you have to continue the Legacy